[Music]
released in 1987 the horror film
hellraiser quickly became a cult classic
to this day the hellraiser franchise
continues to attract a large fan base so
it comes as no surprise that the
upcoming remake is being eyed rather
critically this is partly due to the
fact that the first horror flick has
spawned nine additional movies of which
not all have met the taste of the fans
now the remake is supposed to be
released soon and there are some first
impressions that do look quite promising
among the snaps published by
entertainment weekly is the new casting
of the protagonist pinhead will now be
embodied by sensaid actress jamie
clayton instead of doug bradley this
gives the character a fundamental
makeover which so far has gone down
quite well indeed the change of gender
within the hellraiser universe is no
cause for complaint as the cenobites
created by novelist clive barker are
actually genderless in addition to the
images there is also already a first
teaser which however does not give away
too much about the story also part of
the cast are 13 reasons why star brandon
flynn the boys actor goran visnik blade
runner 2049 actress jaime abbas and
outer banks actor drew starkey there is
still barely any information about the
exact plot but there will probably be
some alterations to the original as the
insider viewer anon announced on twitter
the famous box of the first part is
merely one of many puzzles to be solved
in addition director david bruckner has
already indicated that we should not
assume the remake will be identical in
content do you know the original film
series and if so are you excited about
the remake in the us it is set to be
released exclusively on hulu on october
7th feel free to let us know your
thoughts in the comments
pre-production on the upcoming star wars
series the acolyte is already well
underway before filming starts in
december those responsible must slowly
but surely add new cast members after
drunk history actress amandla stenberg
nightflyer star jody turner smith is now
also part of the acolyte the 36 year old
was originally slated for the lead role
in the witcher blood origin but backed
out before filming even began on disney
plus the acolyte will be the first star
wars live-action series set in the age
of the high republic as the fansite
fulcrum leagues found out some time ago
12 year old aura is to be the focus of
the series she lives on the planet
sanshiro with her grandfather and little
sister miri and has to go through
several adventures after an incident her
sister miri is in danger and so aura
begins to search for her according to
rumors darth plagueis will also be
playing a part in a live-action series
here for the first time in addition many
well-known sith such as darth bane darth
nihilus darth malek and darth revan are
also expected to be involved which would
however miss the cannon in places anyway
nothing has been confirmed or denied by
disney yet so we have to be patient
under the start of the series at the
latest rumor has it that the premiere is
planned for february 2024
there is news about the upcoming dc
blockbuster joker philiadoo both main
actors joaquin phoenix and lady gaga as
joker and harley quinn are known already
and a return of bullet train stars zaizi
beats is also certain now another actor
is joining the cast brendan gleason who
is best known for his role as alistair
moody in the harry potter movies and
even won an emmy for his performance as
winston churchill in 2009 however the 67
year old's role in the joker sequel is
currently unknown also revealed on
thursday was that catherine keener will
be joining the cast as well she is known
for her roles in jordan peels get out
and the atom project and will now play
an unspecified role too sadly there is
still little info on the sequel to the
most successful r-rated film of all time
based on the title however one can at
least anticipate the first storylines
falia do actually describes a mental
illness that can be transmitted from one
person to another so to speak in the
case of the new joker movie this means
that the crazy protagonist will meet
harley quinn and therefore the mentally
disturbed counterpart of himself in
addition the movie is expected to be a
musical that will mainly take place in
the arkham asylum thus the sequel will
differ significantly from the way the
first film was made shooting will start
next december and the movie is scheduled
to be released on october 4th 2024
work is currently in full swing on the
holiday flick red one the netflix film
with a high profile cast around dwayne
johnson and chris evans has recently
been expanded by another actress as
deadline reports we will soon see
kiernan shipka in a still undisclosed
role alongside the two fellow actors
shipka despite her young age of 22 has
been in the business since 2006 and was
most recently seen in chilling
adventures of sabrina and swimming with
sharks behind the camera jake castin is
in charge of directing the film having
previously worked with dwayne johnson on
the two jumanji movies the script comes
from fast and furious writer chris
morgan and is said to feature a somewhat
unusual christmas story it is expected
to go in the direction of an adventure
action comedy and rumor to even feature
dwayne johnson as santa claus we are
definitely excited and look forward to
more news about red one
paramount's historical drama babylon is
scheduled for release in the near future
the film which lasts over three hours is
set between the years 1925 and 1952 and
thus covers several decades of
storylines the focus is on the movie
business in hollywood over the course of
time hence the important transition from
silent films to talkies will also play a
significant role the first person
narrator as well as the main character
is the young manny torres a son of
mexican immigrants who attempts to make
it big in the course of the film he
meets a film icon of the time namely
hollywood prodigy and producer irving
thalberg especially lots of excessive
parties will run like a common thread
through the film as you can already see
from some of the pictures these were
published exclusively by vanity fair as
part of an interview with director
damian giselle and show the top stars in
their roles for the first time the
chemistry between brad pitt and margot
robbie should be particularly
interesting we already got a taste of it
in quentin tarantino's once upon a time
in hollywood the two embody actors who
are at different points in their careers
and according to giselle also contribute
a little of their personal biography to
the role pitt's character jack conrad is
an actor all about work hard play hard
at the absolute peak of his fame he
looks back and wonders where the journey
will take him robbie in contrast plays
an aspiring actress named nelly leroy
who is meant to be reminiscent of real
life actresses jean eagles joan crawford
and alma rubins alongside these two
newcomer diego calva plays the lead role
of manny torres moreover following
spider-man no way home we can look
forward to return of toby maguire who
will play a supporting role in the film
we are definitely excited about babylon
and look forward to its planned
theatrical release on january 6 2023
kids of the 1990s in particular grew up
with the children's series teletubbies
which first started broadcasting in
1997. in a total of five seasons the
four main characters became a phenomenon
of modern pop culture even today
teletubbies is more than just a
children's series that is hard to
remember netflix seems to sense great
potential in the status of the children
series and thus a reboot will soon be
released on the streaming service a
first glimpse of the new series can be
found on twitter where netflix published
the first two images there we see the
well-known figures tinky-winky dipsy
lala and poe as well as the laughing sun
we also learned that respect actor titus
burgess will be performing as the
narrator whether the vacuum cleaner
no-no will also make an appearance is
not yet clear from the pictures and the
information so far we will know more
when the streaming begins on november
14th of this year at the latest
that was the news for this week if you
need more exciting information we
suggest you watch our latest original
episode about phases 5 and 6 of the mcu
in it we take an in-depth look at all
the upcoming marvel movies and series we
hope you enjoy it
[Music]
oh
[Music]